How do I get my PO spinning to the next
level? It's a question lots of PO
spinners will ask themselves. But what
if I told you it's easier than you could
imagine. In fact, I can give you three
minor tweaks that'll make a world of
difference for your spinning and make it
shine even brighter.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video I'm sharing
with you three minor tweaks that'll make
a huge difference in improving your PO
flow. But before we dive in, I just want
to give a quick shout out to the friends
of the channel. Big thanks to Dark Monk,
Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys, Parer,
Light Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to
make the videos on this channel
possible. You can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video.
And special thanks to the non-B business
friend of the channel, Pekka Becklanin.
Thank you so very much for supporting my
channel, my work, and my mission. So,
I'm going to be straight up with all of
you. I think the biggest thing holding
back most po spinners isn't the lack of
difficult tricks or clean technique.
It's that their body mechanics are
pretty sloppy and stiff. I've seen po
spinners of all skill levels make crazy
hard tricks look dull and flat simply by
virtue of looking uncomfortably stiff.
And to be clear, that's not unexpected.
Most of us teach ourselves and practice
in a cramped bedroom. So, it's hardly
surprising that our flow would come to
look pretty cramped as well. But we can
do something about it. And here are
three
examples. Tip number one, turn up the
volume. Show of hands. How many of us
either started off or continue to spin
our poi with T-Rex arms?
Anybody? Buler. Buler. Oh. Um, well, let
me actually raise my hand here so it
stands out. See how big a difference
that makes? The same is going to be true
when you're spinning. When we spin with
T-Rex arms, it doesn't just mean the
patterns we create stand out less and
are unclear. It also means that the
difference between the patterns
themselves is less clear, too. They all
just tend to blur together. The term for
this quality in the dance world is
volume. Namely, when we pull in tight,
close to ourselves, we are said to be
taking up less volume. But if we
consciously extend our arms and give
ourselves permission to eat up some room
and volume, not only do our patterns
read cleaner, they also read more
confidently. They're way more
entertaining to watch, and our
transitions read loud and clear. You can
start challenging yourself to eat up
more room by simply spinning the po in
different spots around your body with
your arms tucked in close as well as
fully extended. Think that you'll do
three beats in as small a space as you
can and then three beats as big as you
can. Move around and pause every so
often and explore this range of motion.
You'll be surprised just how much room
you actually have at your disposal.
Another fun challenge is to make the
rule that you're going to flow for 2
minutes and in that time your elbows are
not allowed to touch your sides nor your
knees touch each other. This forces you
to be more conscious of extending your
body in all different directions and
eating up a lot more volume in the
process. Eating up more volume is a
great first step, but I can also
guarantee that there's another minor
tweak I can give you that will help
clean up your flowers, too. Tip number
two, twist and
shout. So, let me guess. When you were
learning your basic timing and direction
with poi, you learned to do together
same and split opposites like this with
your hands reaching across your body
from side to side. And now when you
perform your flowers, you have this
bizarre little gap between your flowers
on each side. And it's because one of
these things is causing the other. So
check it out. When I move my arms in
either together, same or split
opposites, my hands have a gap between
them at either side because my shoulders
are separated by a gap too. This means
that any pattern I perform with my poi
based upon these arm movements will have
those gaps in them too. And the solution
turns out to be really simple. You just
have to pivot your shoulders back and
forth as you move your arms around. When
you eliminate the gap between your
shoulders, the gap between your hands
and po patterns disappears as well.
Think that as you go back and forth that
you want to point one of your shoulders
out at the audience, so your hands slide
past each other at the sides with
seemingly no gap between them. And yes,
I know the gap is still technically
there, but we're hiding it from the
audience through a trick of perspective.
And that trick helps clean up our PO
patterns as well. I actually did an
entire video on the technique behind
this earlier in the month that I'll link
to down in the description as well as up
in the cards, but suffice it to say,
this very minor tweak will make an
enormous difference in your poi flowers
and hybrids. But the train isn't coming
into the station just yet because I
still have one more minor tweak to share
with you that will make even the
simplest of your po tricks pop and
amaze. Tip number three, think outside
the box. So, I'm going to show you the
same PO trick performed two different
ways. And I want you to tell me honestly
which one is more entertaining to watch.
This right here is a standard windmill.
Nothing fancy, just spinning split time,
same direction shoulder reels and
extending my arms in front. We usually
call this version of the trick Puvian
man. And it's an absolute classic. Now,
I'm going to make a minor tweak. See
that? I started moving my hips around in
a circle with my arms and poi. And all
of a sudden, the move has a completely
different dimension to it. It's more
dynamic, more engaging, and I'd argue
way more entertaining. So, what made the
difference? Well, I made sure to move my
hips outside the box. When you're
standing in place, you can think of
there being kind of a box that comes up
from the floor and goes through your
hips and shoulders. When your hips and
shoulders stay inside the box, I think
the results look kind of boring and
basic. But when you put the effort into
moving your body outside the box, ho ho,
things get very interesting indeed. You
can take a waist strap and add some wow
to
it. You can start with a thread the
needle and throw those stitches for a
loop. Even more advanced tricks like
hybrids benefit from this treatment. Any
way you look at it, shifting outside
that box adds more pop to any trick in
your toolbox. Want more tips like these?
I've got a PDF handout of my top 10 tips
for improving your PO spinning that you
can download completely for free. I'll
leave a link down in the description as
well as up in the cards. Did any of
these tips help you out with your own
flow? Post some video online and make
sure to tag me. I'd love to see the
results of your hard work. Also, be sure
to like, comment, share, and subscribe
to help other people find this video and
to help my channel grow. Thank you.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I want to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much
for your support. You rock. If you'd
like to support the channel, here are
three ways that you can do it. If you'd
like to get your name in the credits or
access to any of a host of awesome
rewards, you can head up my Patreon over
at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo and sign up.
I'll link to it down in the description
as well as up in the cards. If you'd
rather make a one-off contribution, you
can do that via PayPal or Venmo. I am
Drexfactor on both platforms, and I will
leave links to them down in the
description. Thank you so much in
advance. Check out my guide on how to
clean up your flowers at the link down
in the description or the one up on
screen. This is a detailed walkthrough
on how to do that shoulder tweak that I
mentioned earlier, which doesn't just
make your flowers look cleaner, it also
prevents injuries. Make sure to get out
and flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon. Thanks for
watching. Take care and have a good one.
Peace.